Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Lino. Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, wer war jetzt denn eigentlich da in der in der Merkel ihr Pfoten drin?
Womit bewiesen wäre, dass Überwachung überhaupt nicht stattfindet? Alles nur heiße Luft
und äh ja, heiße Luft ist ja auch jetzt nicht das Schlechteste. Viele Leute geben sehr viel Geld aus,
Ja, lange, weite Wegstrecken werden angetreten
werden durchkreuzt, nur mal ein bisschen an heiße Luft ranzukommen. Ist durchaus populär nachgefragt. Ich finde, wir könnten auch mal ein bisschen was produzieren.
Ja, können wir versuchen.
Meinst du das was? Meinst da geht was?
Heißluft können wir.
Wir können auch Heißluft. Ja und äh wir haben auch ähm durchaus die Fühler ähm Zahn der Zeit.
Das weiß ich nicht. Ja.
Doch ein bisschen. Ja. Naja, zumindest bin ich immer wieder froh, wenn wir Nachrichten bringen, die sich auf Dinge beziehen, die wir dann auch schon mal ausführlich diskutiert haben, wo man sich damals so gefragt hat, ob da das manchmal wieder relevant sein wird.
Zum Beispiel wollen wir gleich loslegen.
Was gibt's denn noch, was nochmal relevant wird?
Na ja, vorher weiß man das ja alles nicht. Ich bin immer nur im Nachhinein äh ganz zufrieden.
Ja, ich äh glaube, da habt ihr schon mal gesagt, ne, das ist meine meine Großmutter, die hat immer den Fernseher angemacht und hat gesagt, die Scheiße habe ich ja letzte Woche schon.
Ja. Ja, total.
Und das Problem war, sie hat in der Regel rechts und aber die hatte die war dement, ne, also das war das hat ihn, selbst das hat die noch mitbekommen.
Oh Gott.
Nee, in der Tat nicht. Ja, vielleicht ist das dann auch irgendwann so die Voraussetzung, dass man irgendwie die Sache überhaupt noch geblickt bekommt. Ja, ja.
Die Verrückten sind die beiden Normalen.
Die hat erst rausgehabt, also das ja.
Dann äh steigen wir nochmal kurz ein hier. Also, vor einiger Zeit war's äh irgendwann im oder schon letztes Jahr, ich weiß es mal so ganz genau. Auf jeden Fall gab's mal so diese Nachricht, dass ja bei Belger kommen,
dem quasi dem dem belgischen Äquivalent der deutschen Telekom umfangreiche war Abschnorchelung Vorfälle bekannt,
Wurden, wo äh Unbekannte, ja, Gruppen.
Hat ja nicht nur wie die Telekom irgendwie privat und Firmenkundendienste angeboten, sondern auch.
Mhm. Durchleitung.
Genau. Und ähm,
war auch glaube ich damals schon öffentlich bekannt, äh Fox IT damit beauftragt, da doch mal sich umzuschauen.
Was denn da los ist? Fox IT übrigens diejenigen um die sich noch vor einem Jahr im Sommer, also vor anderthalb Jahren,
große Debatte äh äh,
abgespielt hat bei dem Camp in Holland. Wir hatten ja auch Anne Roth hier bei uns zu Gast, um das ein bisschen zu rekapitulieren, weil die bei der äh Entwicklung eines äh Staatstrojaners nicht ganz unbeteiligt waren.
Genau, das ist auch extrem kontrovers diskutiert worden in der Szene und auch vor Ort auf der Veranstaltung.
Ja hat äh da hatte man dann das äh hatte man dann das Thema, mit dem man sich die Laune verderben konnte,
und das wurden natürlich dann auch gemacht. Ähm.
Politik vierundsiebzig äh Verlust hat, da nochmal reinzuhören, so es noch nicht getan hat.
Wie Leute haben das nicht gehört.
Du, es gibt ja auch immer wieder Leute, die erst jüngst zu uns äh gestoßen sind, deren erste Aufgabe jetzt nicht unbedingt das komplett Archiv nachzuhören. Ansonsten.
Erste Aufgabe, sonst verstehen wir überhaupt nicht den Kontex.
Ansonsten sind unsere, hm.
Das ist ja wie zwischendrin Tatort anfangen, weiß ja gar nicht, wer tot ist.
Da kann man sich manchmal gar nicht mehr dran, man kann sich gar nicht dafür entscheiden, was man jetzt sozusagen alles nochmal anschauen will und was einfach auch die Lieblingsfolge war.
Deswegen schaut man das hier auch chronologisch durch. Logbuch, Logbuch ist ja nicht irgendwie ein Schmöcker, wo man mal reinschauen kann. Ach, guck mal hier. Letzte Woche. Nein, das wird hier bitte, da da muss man ein bisschen Disziplin kann man das schon verlangen.
Genau, unser Beitrag zur nordischen Metaphern, ein Erfolgsmodell der nutzpolitischen Szene.
Beim Thema jetzt oder wie?
Du hast hier angefangen mit irgendwelchen.
Entschuldigung, ich wollte nur einen höheren Service machen, dass du da gleich so ein Fass aufmachst, kann ich nur nicht ahnen.
Ich, ich, ich finde das einfach nicht in Ordnung, wenn die Hörer hier nicht äh nicht diszipliniert bei der Sache bleiben. Wir machen es ja nicht zum Spaß.
Folx IT ist bei bei Belgercom reingegangen und äh äh Rodelallen Roland oder Ronald? Ich vergesse immer, wie man ihn äh wie man ihn nennt.
Roland, Prinz.
Na ja, das, was du jetzt grade abgelesen habe, hast, habe ich selber geschrieben, deswegen weiß ich nicht, ob ich's richtig geschrieben habe. Ja, okay.
Okay. Mich überprüft.
Gut. Der da, der sagt einfach nur, er dürfte nicht drüber sprechen. Auf jeden Fall ist jetzt noch mal in den Medien, ähm weil es sich darüber dann geäußert hat, der Spionage Trojaner mit dem Namen Regine,
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie man das ausspricht.
Das weiß man erst, wenn man Zugang hat zu diesem geheimen Zirkel.
Nenne ihn jetzt Regien. Regien ist quasi die ähm,
Trojaner, der dessen Entwicklung auf NSA und GCAQ zurück,
der pflanzt sich irgendwie fort. Oh je, jetzt Tim, hebt den mahnenden Zeigefinger.
Doch Ronald. Sorry.
Ja, wunderbar, danke Tim.
Mein Beitrag zu einer unterhaltsamen.
Wenigstens mal ein Fehler, der noch in der Sendung korrigiert wird.
Ja.
Die meisten werden ja gar nicht korrigiert. Wir machen das ja nur um eure Medienkompetenz zu prüfen.
Und unsere.
So, also Regin pflanzt sich fort entnetzten, transportiert Daten ab,
äh ist da relativ spezialisiert darauf, was er ab äh abtransportiert,
Und das Schöne ist, Regine äh ist modular. Das heißt, man kann ihm bestimmte Module einbauen. Ähm zum Beispiel,
irgendwie ein Key-Locker, wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, derjenige, der den ich da in filetriert habe, der gibt relativ viele Passwörter ein. Dann möchte ich ihm natürlich einen Key-Locker äh unterschieben, damit ich die an diese Passwörter bekomme. Aber wenn ich zum Beispiel sehe, derjenige.
Hat direkt 'n Administrationszugriff auf Teile eines Telefonnetzes, dann könnte man natürlich auch,
dort aus Anfang dieses Telefonnetz zu infiltrieren und dazu äh sind ist Regien offensichtlich,
offenbar laut diesen Schilderungen in der Lage, es gäbe also einen Teil, der äh spezifisch spezifisch sogar darauf abgerichtet ist, Mobilfunknetz,
Komponenten zu infiltrieren, das ist eigentlich sage ich mal was, was man eher für.
Nicht ausgeschlossen, aber nicht als das zentrale Bedrohungsszenario gehalten hat. Ähm.
Ähm so wie es aussieht, schieben sie einem das Ding eben über Quantum Inserd unter,
Das ist dieses äh wir manipulieren dein Internet-Traffic,
während du ihn ausführst, wir antworten dir schneller als dein eigenes.
Also das ist der Kotnahme der NSA-Code für diesen für diesen Angriffsszenario.
Genau und bei Belger kommen stellte sich ja auch raus, dass sie denen das eben über manipulierte LinkedIn Seiten,
zugeführt haben. Das heißt, sie haben den Quellcode der Seite irgendwie verändert und dann was weiß ich,
ändern, im PDF-Datei, aus der du dann rauskletterst und diejenigen infizierst oder irgendeinen Flash-Film aus.
War doch diese Methode, wo also irgendein Mitarbeiter greift jetzt auf eine linke Seite zu und noch bevor der LinkedIn-Server in der Lage, ist die richtige Seite zu liefern, wird quasi im Netz
das abgezweigt und stattdessen antwortet ein NSA-Server schneller und dann liefert er halt quasi etwas Ähnliches aus, bloß mit dem Schadcode. War das das?
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was das ist, aber ähm es könnte auch einfach eine ganz normale, männende Mittelseite sein.
Ob jemand dazwischen ist,
Nee, es macht schon einen Unterschied, aber also sie manipulieren eine, sie sind in der Lage, eine Seite zu manipulieren, die du aufrufst, ja? Und dann bauen sie da irgendwas ein, dass das dich dann möglichst infiziert. Das sind im Zweifelsfall dann diese äh viel gelobten, viel gesuchten,
und teuer auf dem Markt zu erstehenden Drivebikes, also du musst nur eine Seite öffnen und kannst ähm dadurch ein dein Opfer oder kannst dich dadurch infizieren lassen.
Dadurch haben sie es offensichtlich den Leuten untergeschoben, bei bei Belger kommen, wurde eben bekannt, dass sie es über LinkedIn-Seiten gemacht haben.
Ähm dieses,
Dieser Regen, wir nennen jetzt ihn, weil er ja böse ist, also männlich. Ähm,
Der hat äh ein eigenes Kommunikationsrückkanalnetz, äh das
tor ähnlich funktioniert, also äh das ist auch eine Sache, hatten wir vor einiger Zeit mal besprochen. Wenn du so einen Trojaner basttelst, der irgendwie Daten ex filtriert und irgendwie nach Hause schicken muss, dann muss der das ja über,
über irgendeinen Kanal tun und es wäre jetzt so, sage ich mal,
geschicktere Variante, dass er das durch das normale Internet zu einer bestimmten IP macht?
Denn das ist ja dann wiederum leicht zu erkennen und äh zu filtern,
eleganter ist es natürlich, wenn er das irgendwie auf Umwegen tut, zum Beispiel durch das Tornetz, ja? Ähm oder eben durch ein ähnliches,
durch eine ähnliche Art von Verschleierungs-Traffic sich so tarnt, dass er nicht auffällt als als äh unter,
Ähm und über ein Viertel der Infektionen.
Die bekannt sind, äh,
Hätten also bei Telekommunikationsunternehmen stattgefunden. Das heißt, die haben sich wirklich äh die Mühe gemacht, einen Trojaner zu bauen, der wirklich ganz spezifisch und gezielt ähm Telekommunikations äh Netze und Netzanbieter,
infiltriert. Ähm das ist jetzt.
Wie gesagt, bis auf den Teil, dass sie's sogar bis in die Netze vorgedrungen sind, ähm nicht wirklich was Neues, dass äh.
Trojaner zum Einsatz kommen,
Staaten oder zur Spionage, aber das Niveau, was hier von allen Seiten so hoch gelobt wird, ist natürlich schon ähm,
Interessant für Menschen, die sich damit auseinandersetzen. Mhm. Damit einhergeht natürlich auch.
Immer gesagt, naja, die Menge an Daten,
du eigentlich nicht aus so einem Telefonnetz raus, ohne dass das der ähm dem Betreiber auffallen,
könnte und den Geheimdiensten auffallen sollte,
sodass ich's immer für wahrscheinlicher gehalten habe, dass sie mit den Geheimdiensten,
ähm mit den lokalen Geheimdiensten kooperieren. Was sie ja auch tun,
oder dass der, dass der Geheimdienst direkt mit dem Netzanbieter kooperiert, was er auch tut, kommen wir gleich noch zu,
aber offensichtlich, wenn sie gar nichts haben, dann trojanisieren sie eben auch einfach, dass direkt das ganze Netz und das haben sie eben bei äh
diese Sache an die Sache erinnere ich mich schon gar nicht mehr in in ihrem vollen Ausmaß. Aber ist schon eine eine interessante,
interessanter Punkt zu hören, dass sie also wirklich.
Sehr hohe, sehr hohe Aufwände da betreiben. Und in die viel gerühmten und viel diskutierten,
Zero Days, die der BND gerne kaufen möchte. Das ist genau, wo man solche Sachen dann eben drin unterbringt, ne, dass man irgendwie äh,
Möglichkeiten braucht, wenn man erstmal in der Lage ist, Code aus äh auszuführen auf seinem Zielsystem, dass man dann noch in der Lage ist, auch äh Administratorrechte zu bekommen, um die Kiste völlig zu ordnen und genau solche,
Sicherheitslücken, die keinem bekannt sind. Äh die benötigt man für derartige Angriffe. Und da geht dieses Geld dann oder da
Da kommt das Geld her und da gehen diese äh geht das Wissen über diese Schwachstellen dann hin.
Aber war Fox IT nicht auch selber mit Spionage Entschuldigung mit so Staatstrojaner, Projekten.
Genau, das hatte ich eingangs, das hatte ich eingangs erwähnt.
Und die werden sozusagen von Belger kommen, dann.
Ja, wen willst du denn sonst holen? Ist doch ideal, holst dir diejenigen, die die äh schon mal,
natürlich, nicht selber geschrieben. Ähm
haben ja, glaube ich, ich weiß nicht mehr genau für weil ob das jetzt Belgien oder die Niederlande waren, wo wir irgendwie einen Staatstrianer programmiert hatten,
grade nicht so ganz sicher, aber die haben auf jeden Fall Ahnung von so was sind Security-Leute
Klar.
Aber jetzt so Informationen über dieses, was bei dieser Untersuchung konkret herauskam.
Ich würde von diesem Bagger kommen Ding gerne weg, weil der sagt, er er spricht da nicht drüber. Es ist noch nicht mal hundertprozentig sicher, dass es bei Belger kommen wirklich Regien war, nur Ronald Prinz sagte eben,
ohne dass er nach Belger kommt gefragt worden wäre in einem Interview. Also ich darf natürlich jetzt nicht über irgendwas sprechen, was bei Belger kommen,
ist, aber es gibt zum Beispiel Trojaner, die folgendes tun. Also das war so, ja?
Es gibt und da da geht sie da,
speist sich dieser schöne Zero-Day-Markt von, das am Ende solche Entwicklungen rauskommt, das Geheimdienste. Unsere Infrastruktur angreifen,
Ne und das äh kommt natürlich, wird natürlich dann auch nochmal relevant, wenn man so an diese Fälle zurückdenkt der Deutschen Telekom und,
offensichtlich abgegraben wurden. Das scheint dann so die Software zu sein, die dabei zum Einsatz kam.
Und es ist immer so in der, wenn du jetzt hier wie so ein Telekommunikationsunternehmen führst, immer natürlich eine der Schwachstellen, vor der äh gewarnt wird oder um die du dir Sorgen machst, dass deine Administratoren.
Gehackt werden.
Das ist auch das, was hier äh also das ist ein sinnvolles Einfallstor und das wurde hier auch genutzt.
Wenn man so einen Aufwand betreibt man natürlich nur da, wo man nicht einfach klopfen kann.
Also warum sollte ich mir die Mühe geben, einen Trojaner entwickeln, dessen Entdeckung zu riskieren und irgendwie mich über Monate oder Jahre in irgend so eine Infrastruktur reinzuhecken,
Wenn ich auch einfach sagen kann, Kollegen, wie sieht's aus?
Dass äh hat dann der Partner Cable and wirs,
ein traditionsreicher und wohlklingender Name im Bereich der untersiekabel Betreiberunternehmen.
Getan und wurde zweitausendzwölf von,
Vodafone übernommen. Jetzt ist natürlich unklar,
Ob die das weitermachen oder nicht, aber es wäre jetzt natürlich erstaunlich, wenn Vodafon ausgerechnet wo davon derartige Kooperationen plötzlich beenden würde. Zumal, wenn sie sogar noch bezahlt werden. Da gibt's jetzt eine,
ausführliche Excel-Tabelle, wo äh GCAQ mit wessen Hilfe Zugriff auf welches Unterseekabel hat.
Das ist natürlich.
Kommt die diese Tabelle her.
Vom Edford, vom Edward. Und die wurde veröffentlicht, ich glaube von der.
Von NDR, WDR und Süddeutsche Zeitung, das ist ja so das Deutsche eines der deutschen Rechercheteams, die dieses Norden Sachen untersuchen,
die haben das veröffentlicht auf ähm auf irgendwie ich glaube Google Drive.
Was?
Google Drive, ja. Na ja, okay, ähm haben sie veröffentlicht und ähm da gibt's also eine eine Liste der.
Der der Kabel, auf die sie eben Zugriff haben. Und da kommt taucht ein Unternehmen relativ häufig vor äh drinnen auf und das ist eben dieses Unternehmen,
was der Codename ist für Cable und Wireless.
Das steht da auch drin. Das Girontik, weil es ist.
Das steht in dem Artikel. Ich habe mir diese Liste jetzt nicht so genau angeschaut, weil ich kein Experte bin. Ähm da musste dann, da müssen sich andere dransetzen. Das hat den Namen des Kabels. Dann siehst du, wem das gehört,
und dann siehst du, wer äh wo das ankommt, nämlich in den UK-Pottington, zum Beispiel hier ein Kabel, was ich mir angeschaut habe und dann steht da irgendwie drin, wie viel da,
wie viel Kapazität also welche Bandbreite dieses Kabel hat und welche Bandbreite,
mit mit welcher Bandbreite sie darauf zugreifen können und hier steht dann zum Beispiel bei einem,
äh ein Kabel, das C und W gehört,
der Partner wäre eben Gironic. Ja, das heißt, da haben sie offensichtlich diesen Codenham benutz.
Ja, das heißt, wir haben jetzt eine schöne Liste, auf welche Untersuche Sie Zugriff haben. Vor ein paar Jahren, also es anfangs um Unterseekabel ging, da wurden dann mal einzelne Kabel benannt beim Namen, ne? Und jetzt wissen wir,
Das ist natürlich ganz schön interessant und man kann natürlich hoffen, dass da jetzt andere sich drum,
kümmern, dass das auch aufhört. Zweitausendneun hatte,
GCHQ Zugriff auf äh insgesamt knapp siebentausend,
Gigabit pro Sekunde und siebzig Prozent seiner Zuggriffe wurden realisiert mit der Hilfe von,
C und W. Aber es gibt auch andere Unternehmen in diesen Listen, zum Beispiel British Telekom, mit dem Code Namen Ramady,
Level drei mit dem Codenam.
Wird ihm bestimmt nicht gefallen.
Was wird dir nicht gefallen, dass sie in dieser Liste stehen oder was? Nein.
Beleidigung.
Das das könnte also dann die die Geschäftsbeziehung äh negativ beeinflussen oder beeinträchtigen,
Aber zumindest was angeht, äh scheint es sehr freundlich zu sein. Da gibt's dann so ähm Einträge in den,
in den Tagebüchern. Äh wir haben ihnen die Spezifikationen der Kernkomponenten Komponenten gegeben. Dann müssen sie jetzt die internen Tests,
und wenn die erfolgreich verlaufen, haben wir bald schon äh Zugriff und können hier irgendwie eine
erste Machbarkeitsstudie selber durchführen und so weiter. Und es sind größere Geldbeträge im Budget verzeichnet, die dann auch eben an Cable and Wireless
gegangen sind. Wo davon hält sich dazu geschlossen.
Sagt gar nix, aber die sagen ja eigentlich sowieso nichts. Also irgendwie das BS,
mal bei denen nachgefragt hat, wie sieht's denn hier aus mit der Mobilfunksicherheit und,
überhaupt und wir hatten bei euch wo davon immer die einzigen, die keine zufriedenstellende Antwort gegeben haben.
Aufgekriegt.
Ja, also so läuft es, ne? Danke Vodafone.
Ja, also um's mal vielleicht nochmal so von oben zu gucken, also es scheint so, als ob alle großen Glasfaserkabelbetreiber, wenn nicht sogar alle.
Da mit den Briten zusammenarbeiten. Kann man das so sagen.
Um's mal so ganz einfach zusammenzufassen.
In Zugriff auf die Glasfaserkabel betrifft,
Man hätte ja vielleicht am Anfang auch noch das Gefühl bekommen können, das wären jetzt so Ausnahmen oder Einzelfälle oder so, aber es scheint einfach so zu sein, dass man gar nicht auch nur ein Kabel in dieses Land reinstecken kann, von außen,
Also alles, was er sozusagen so aus dem Wasser gekrochen kommt und äh Daten anliefert, das kriegt erstmal ein Tab. Aber wird auch bezahlt dafür.
Ja, es ist jetzt auch nicht mehr überraschend, ne.
Nee, ich sage nicht, es ist überraschend, ich wollte es nur einfach mal so festgehalten haben, weil man kann ja in diesen ganzen Details immer sich auch schnell,
verlieren, wie viel Gigabit jetzt hier und da mitgeschrieben werden, so die eigentliche Botschaft ist halt das.
Jo, wollen wir nach Deutschland wechseln?
Die Addas sehr schön, da gab's jetzt eine NSA Untersuchungsausschusssitzung,
Die war aber strengstens geheim. Wirklich. Ja.
Zwar ist das ja immer so, die BND-Mitarbeiter, die kommen da rein zur öffentlichen Sitzung.
Da erzählen sie dann schön für die Journalisten, die dort sitzen. Ja, alles kein Problem
ne? Ist alles wie ist er der Satellit ist ja im Feldraum. Das ist ja
gilt ja gar kein Gesetz, gegen das wir verstoßen können und äh massenhafte Daten, das stimmt ja alles gar nicht, ne? Ist ja die jetzt nicht maßenhaft.
Und ähm dann geht's ja irgendwann in die Nicht-öffentliche Sitzung, in der sie dann wirklich mal ins ähm,
ins Verhör genommen werden, ja? Und wo sie dann zum Beispiel auch mal mit Beweisen konfrontiert werden können,
die dem, was sie in der öffentlichen Sitzung erzählt haben,
widersprechen, ja? Und.
Jetzt hatte unser guter Freund Peter Altmaier ja schon angedroht, dass er das nicht gut findet, wenn aus den,
diesen nichtöffentlichen Sachen Besitzungen dann doch irgendwie Details öffentlich werden.
Ja, wo wo kommen wir denn da hin, wenn jetzt die, wenn das die Presse ihre Arbeit macht, dann.
Genau, oder der Untersuchungsausschuss irgendwie was untersucht und irgendwie Erkenntnisse zu Tage,
ja, also es wäre jetzt ein es geht ja jetzt nicht, dass dieser Untersuchungsausschuss,
Ausschuss zur Aufklärung dieser dieser Dinge beiträgt,
Ne? Ich meine, das ist ja schon schlimm genug,
jetzt hier, was hier alles an Geheimnissen auf dem Tisch liegt. Und jetzt ähm,
Wurde also plötzlich diese nichtöffentliche Vernehmung als streng,
geheim eingest eingestuft. Und bei streng geheim.
Brauchst du quasi eine,
abgeschlossene Sicherheitsüberprüfung. Also, es gibt quasi eine,
einen sicherlich sehr schön durchbürokratisierten Prozess.
Bist du Zugriff auf,
Verschlusssache, streng geheim, haste nicht gesehen, überhaupt bekommst. Und das müssten mussten natürlich jetzt alle,
vorweisen, die in diesen Untersuchungsausschuss sitzen beziehungsweise insbesondere die Mitarbeiter,
verschiedenen Ministerien. Und das führte also dazu, dass einige,
Sitzung zunächst verlassen mussten, weil sie erstmal von ihrem Ministerium die ähm,
diese diese Nachweis über die Sicherheitsprüfung rüberfuchsen lassen mussten,
einigen gab's dieses Fax halt nicht und die mussten dann auch draußen bleiben, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Oh Gott.
Problem.
Ist jetzt, dass sich die Opposition, die an dieser,
teilgenommen hat, nicht mehr traut, darüber zu sprechen,
weil es ja streng geheim. Und streng geheim heißt, äh.
Ist ähm diese Informationen können den Bestand der Bundesrepublik Deutschland oder eines ihrer Länder gefährden.
Den Bestand.
Ja, also es bricht alles auseinander oder mit anderen Worten,
was unter streng geheim ist. Das ist natürlich dann auch geheimnisverrat, wenn du das äußerst.
Und ist natürlich ein Unterschied zu sagen, okay, wir haben hier eine nicht-öffentliche Sitzung.
Der dann eventuell jemand rausgeht und sagt, wir haben in dieser Sitzung erfahren, dass es bestimmte Kooperationen gibt, die äh nach meinem Ermessen als äh Bürger dieses Landes nicht,
verfassungsgemäß sind.
Wo der Mann also ohne Beweise rausgeht und eine Behauptung aufstellt, wie wir jetzt in diesem Bereich ja schon sehr viele haben,
ob du dran schreibst, streng geheim, das heißt, egal, was du daraus trägst, du riskierst irgendwie,
So die Berichterstattung eine spürbare Einschüchterung der,
Teilnehmer dieser streng geheimen Sitzung.
Hatten wir nicht. Jetzt ist mir gerade ein Fall. Aber hatten wir nicht im Rahmen des Untersuchungsausschusses, auch vor ein paar Wochen schon so ein Fall, wo so ein bisschen,
mit ein wenig aus dem Nähkästchen äh plauderte und dann auch schon so erste Überlegungen.
Ja, wir hatten diese Androhung, wir hatten diese schriftliche Androhung von Altmaier an den äh Vorsitzenden des Untersuchungsausschusses, dass er doch bitte äh einstellen möge, dass irgendwelcher Mistaufnetzpolitik Org landet.
Ja, das scheint jetzt so die zweite Stufe zu sein. Dass man sich gesagt hat, okay.
Jetzt machen wir das auch mal vom.
Machen wir das mal, machen wir mal ein paar Geschäftsordnungstricks.
Mhm. Hm. Nicht schön. Aber so läuft es.
Es ist halt, es ist wieder nur eine weitere äh skurrile Blüte dieser ganzen Angelegenheit, ne.
Wie gesagt, wenn du den wenn du deinen eigenen Geheimdienst da zum zum Aussagen bringen möchtest, dann musst du dem wahrscheinlich auch solche ähm,
Möglichkeiten einräumen, ne.
Aber das Schöne ist ja, wenn alle streng geheim ist, dann gibt's ja auch keine Beweise. Und dann kann man ein Verfahren einstellen,
zum Beispiel das Verfahren um das Abhören des Kanzlerinnen Handys. Das wird jetzt eingestellt,
ja und da das finde ich jetzt wirklich sehr schön, ja.
Das Verfahren, das Ermittlungsverfahren wird eingestellt aus Mangel an Beweisen.
Und das ist natürlich, was ähm ein rechtsstaatliches Prinzip, wenn du keinen,
Beweis anbringen kannst, also jeder kann jeden für jeden Scheiß anzeigen. Ich kann dich jetzt morgen äh was weiß ich, anzeigen, weil du irgendetwas.
Aufnahme verkackt.
Die Aufnahme verkackt. Ja oder für die,
mehr so stark zunehmenden Hörerzahlen,
Bist du verantwortlich, dadurch entsteht mir direkter seelischer Schaden,
Und dafür mache ich dich verantwortlich. So und dann ist halt die Frage, gibt es Beweise dafür, dass bei Logbuch Netzpolitik die Hörerzahlen nicht mehr so stark zunehmen wie in den vergangenen Jahren? Und diese Beweise äh könnte es nur du bringen.
Ja, ist streng geheim.
Ist streng geheim oder ähm du machst, wir machen hier keine Loks oder so, ne. Und.
Einfach streng geheim. Ich kann da nichts zu sagen.
Dann würde dieses Verfahren, dann würde dieses Verfahren aus Mangel an Beweisen eingestellt. Das ist natürlich auch wichtig so, weil du Leute, die ähm.
Dinge, die die nicht beweisbar sind, dafür möchtest du eben Leute auch nicht in den Knast stecken können,
wenn das, wenn wir ja von diesem Prinzip abweichen,
Dann haben wir natürlich das Problem, dass wir einer äh staatlichen Willkür wieder ausgesetzt sind. Ne, dass Leute auf Verdacht,
weggeschlossen werden. Das ist immer etwas, wogegen wir uns aus guten Gründen sehr entschieden wären,
ja?
Wenn Leute ohne Beweis oder dass es einen, dass es ein eine vernünftige Aussicht auf ein strafrechtliches Verfahren gibt, festgehalten werden können.
Zum Beispiel in Guantanamo, ja, wo man Leute ohne Beweise festhält und ohne Aussicht auf ein Verfahren, weil man sich von diesen,
Prinzipien verabschiedet hat.
Jetzt ist natürlich das Problem, der Geheimdienst hat sich aber von allen rechtsstaatlichen Prinzipien verabschiedet,
und du wirst ihn halt auch nicht näher kommen, wenn du dich weiter an diese rechtsstaatlichen Prinzipien halten möchtest.
Also es steht außer Frage.
Dass dieses Abhören von von Angela Merkels Handy äh stattgefunden hat, einfach schon, weil es so einfach möglich ist. Warum sollten die Trojaner bauen, ähm um belgische,
zu zu infiltrieren.
Knacken. Wenn das aufm Niveau möglich ist, dass sogar äh ich das irgendwie vorführen kann.
Mal im Gegensatz zu dem hausinternen Netz und den Kabeln von Belger kommen, halt das Handytelefon halt einfach durch die Luft fliegt.
Genau und deshalb zumindest, wenn es sich jetzt
so nach, nach momentan stand der Technik, um ein GSM Telefonat handelt, dann brauchst du noch nicht mal eine aktive Maßnahme zu ergreifen. Ähm was jetzt so bei 3G-Telefonaten
ist äh wird sich, denke ich mal, in den nächsten,
Wochen dann vielleicht noch zeigen so beim Chaos Communication Kongress sind da einige Vorträge eingereicht, die äh auf einige interessante Ergebnisse der Forschung in diesem Bereich hindeuten. Aber,
Es sieht danach aus, dass du relativ wenig Spuren hinterlassen musst,
Wenn du so ein Telefonanruf abhörst. Ja, einem 2G-Bereich eben,
tatsächlich überhaupt gar keine.
Sind mittlerweile so dermaßen gut dokumentiert und die Angriffsszenarien sind so mit vertretbarem Hardwareaufwand durchführbar, dass halt einfach eine Verschlüsselung an der Stelle überhaupt nicht mehr schützt.
Zusammengefasst.
Ja man, also es gibt es gibt einfach, es gibt verschiedene Fehler, die da zusammenkommen, dass diese ähm A fünf eins Verschlüsselung insgesamt nicht kompliziert genug ist und du gleichzeitig
Einige Fehlerhass in den Paketen, die da durchgehen, die es dir ermöglichen, einen ähm,
einen Angriff zu machen,
auf diese Verschlüsselung, du brauchst ja immer sowas, dass du einen Teil des Inhaltes kennst, um zu verifizieren, ob du vernünftig äh ob du richtig entschlüsselt hast und das ist inzwischen oder seit einigen Jahren mit relativ,
Aufwand,
und ne, das ist ja auch seit Jahren bekannt. Also es gäbe jetzt keinen Grund, warum ein Geheimdienst genau das nicht,
Du musst es ja erstmal beweisen. Und dazu äh sehen Sie sich jetzt nicht in der Lage und das finde ich eine sehr interessante.
Finde ich einen sehr interessanten Punkt,
Sie wüssten, Sie, Sie haben keine Beweise dafür, dass es stattgefunden hat, ja, weil du einfach eine Antenne aufstellen kannst und das Telefonat empfängst, entschlüsselst
und fertig. Wenn dir nicht nachher die,
die Festplatte mit den entschlüsselten Telefonaten verloren geht, äh gibt es keinen Beweis.
Und auch einen, das auf irgendeinem, auf irgendeiner Folie von steht, Zielperson der Kommunikation. Da hast du noch nicht den,
Den tatsächlichen Punkt nachgewiesen, dass es tatsächlich wann, wo, wie stattgefunden hat. Das reicht nicht für eine Verurteilung.
Und ich würde auch nicht dafür in,
in in anderen Bereichen eben natürlich sehr stark engagiere für diese rechtsstaatlichen Prinzipien. Und die Herausforderung, vor der wir jetzt stehen, ist, ja.
Der Geheimdienst scheiß da völlig drauf,
unsere eigenen Geheimdienste scheißen auf diese Prinzipien, wenn sie sich in anderen Ländern ähm,
engagieren. Wir wissen noch nicht mal, ob diese,
Prinzipien von den deutschen Inlandsgeheimdiensten wirklich gewahrt werden. Alle, alle Bürgerrechte, die wir so in unserem, unserer Verfassung eingeräumt bekommen,
Und genau aus diesem Grund gibt es ja auch diese Trennung, um das nochmal in größeren Kontext zu setzen. Genau aus diesem Grund gibt es ja die Trennung von Geheimdiensten und Polizei,
Nach Gutdünken alles abhören, wie sie wollen. Der Geheimdienst kann das schon machen, musste ich darüber auch jetzt nicht unbedingt in Kenntnis setzen,
der kann aber nicht dazu führen oder der der kann nicht darauf hinarbeiten, dass du einer Verurteilung äh zugeführt wirst. Ja, das heißt, die die.
Ungesetzlich abgehörten Telefonate, die der Geheimdienst sammelt, darf er nicht der Polizei,
zuschanzen, damit du am Ende vor Gericht damit stehst, ne.
Aber es gibt ja seit vielen Jahren und jetzt auch in letzter Zeit auch wieder neu. Also diese Forderung nach Koordinationszentren.
Genau, haben wir ja hier auch einen stehen, ne? In ähm in, wie heißt das Tripau? Ja.
Genau. Ne? Und das ist halt eigentlich genau das, was so beim Design des äh Grundgesetzes der Bundesrepublik mal ganz,
anders gedacht war, weil man damit eben die entsprechend schlechten
Erfahrungen gemacht hat, in der Nazizeit und bisher hat sich das eigentlich als durchaus hilfreich erwiesen
aber na ja, wie das immer so ist, man will ja immer eine schlagkräftige Polizei haben. Man muss ja auch, kann ja nicht sein, dass man Informationen, die man hat, nicht nutzen kann und diese ganze Politikerrhetorik, das ist immer das, was eben genau diesen Punkt aufweicht und.
Um nochmal auf den Punkt zurückzukommen. Ich finde das natürlich, es war mit nichts anderem zu rechnen, als es dieses Verfahren aus Mangel, aus Beweisen eingestellt würde.
Ja? Selbst wenn sie jetzt einen aktiven ähm genutzt hätten und es irgendwie darüber gäbe, dass die ja zum Einsatz gekommen ist, ne, wenn sagen wir mal die die Bundesregierung hätte da irgendwie,
hättest du immer noch nicht den Beweis, wer den aufgestellt hat, ja? Also das nachzuweisen ist,
schwierig und in diesem Fall nicht gelungen und wir müssen uns jetzt überlegen,
oder nicht? Ich persönlich bin da echt gespalten. Ich bin da wirklich gespalten, also.
Aufregend, dass jetzt diese Ermittlungen eingestellt wurden.
Wo willst du jetzt hier irgendwie anfangen? Also das ist ja dann auch am Ende einfach jetzt nicht so der Schocker,
darauf jetzt irgendwie äh sinnlose Ressourcen zu zu gießen, halte ich auch irgendwie für,
Blödsinn, dafür sind die eigentlich die ist die Erkenntnislage schon klar, beziehungsweise kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass ich irgendjemand mittlerweile noch irgendwelche Illusionen mache. Das ist halt nur insofern jetzt so ein so ein Aufhänger, weil das halt so gefühlt äh das erste Mal war,
Das so eine allgemeine äh Politempörung überhaupt stattfand im Rahmen dieses gesamten Skandals. Als es eben auf einmal um das Telefon der Kanzlerin ging. Ja, als ob.
Interessant. Es ist ja nicht so, als würden unsere Geheimdienste das nicht tun.
Betonen. Was ich ganz interessant finde ist, dass die Bundesregierung natürlich jetzt einerseits immer so sagte, ja Mister verschlüsseln und so, ne, auch aufm Smartphone und so, ne, keine Frage, muss ja Krypto Krypto-Telefone kaufen oder so, ne? Und
Gleichzeitig setzt sich aber das äh das Innenministerium hin und sagt, ja äh die Kriminellen, ne, die verschlüsseln jetzt, wir brauchen irgendwie äh
Angriffsvektoren dagegen erhöht mal bitte unser Budget,
Und das ist was, was ich hier die ganze Zeit sehe und das das zieht sich durch diese ganzen Themen
die wir ähm hier besprochen haben, den Spionage Trojaner Regine, dieses,
Jeder spielt dieses Spiel mit und wir haben
zentralen Interessenskonflikt der Regierung selber, die sagen, wir wollen einerseits Zerodays kaufen und selber Trojaner bauen, wir wollen,
abhören, wir möchten nicht, dass die Menschen verschlüsselt kommunizieren, wenn,
Verschlüsselungsverfahren zunehmen, dann fragen wir sofort nach mehr Geld, um diese wieder zu,
zu brechen oder irgendwie zu unterwandern oder zu äh umgehen oder Angriffe auf auf die auf die Endpunkte durchzuführen.
Aber es hält sich die Balance, ne, dass man einerseits die Spionage abwehren möchte, andererseits versuchen möchte,
Dafür zu sorgen, dass sie möglich, dass sie einem selbst möglich bleibt. Und das ist natürlich ein Wettrüsten, was da stattfindet.
Heizt einfach nur diese Industrie auf, die genau solche Dinge ermöglicht
Ah, hallo Berger, komm, ah, ihr habt ihr wurdet irgendwie von den von den ähm Briten
geordnet. Na dann lasst, schickt uns mal unsere Berater rein, die kratzen das da wieder raus, ja? Ah, hallo, ach so, ihr wollt jetzt in kein Problem, da haben wir Ahnung von. Wir haben zum Beispiel schon mal einen analysiert, weißt du so ähm
Dazwischen drin bewegt sich diese diese ja diese Industrie für Sicherheit und äh.
Spielt er einfach in äh teilweise eben in alle Richtungen mit. Und das wird so vermutlich,
Weitergehen, weil die Anreize, die unsere Regierung in dem Bereich setzt, auch genau dahin zeigen, ja, dass sie sagen, ja, okay, das wäre ganz gut, wenn ihr hier mal ein bisschen verschlüsselt und dann können wir vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen Wirtschaftsförderung machen oder so, ne?
Aber wenn wenn das irgendwie überhand nimmt mit dem Verschlüssel, dann müssen, brauchen wir auf jeden Fall auch ein Budget, um das wieder angreifen zu können, ne. Das äh.
So dreht sich das alles im Kreis.
So dreht sich das im Kreis und solange das das BSI irgendwie unter dem.
Ja
Das vielleicht mal so um zu zeigen, wie also ich finde in dieser Folge zeigt sich sehr dieser dieses äh Spannungsfeld aus,
der eigenen Interessen, die die verschiedenen äh Player haben, die sich am Ende aber nur auf auf Budgets runterbrechen und in der Mitte ist dann eben,
die Industrie, äh die solche Sachen produziert,
und dagegen kämpft, ja? Das ist also nichts anderes als ein.
Als ein Wettrüsten. Und fernab von allem, was irgendwie Rechtsstaat oder sonst was ist.
Gut kommen wir ähm zur europäischen Politik, genauer zur EU und dort,
wird es jetzt wohl eine Prüfung geben, ob die Übermittlung von Fluggastdaten, das sogenannte PNR.
Was ja lange Zeit schon aktiv ist. Es ging also zweitausendeins los. Das heißt, die USA angefangen haben, na ja, ihr wollt in den USA fliegen, alles supi, aber dann müssen wir vorher mal so die Daten haben und wir hätten auch gerne mal so alles, wer da alles so fliegt
und zwar gar nicht mal nur Leute, die äh in die USA einreisen wollen, sondern auch die da so im Transitz sind, et cetera pp. Und dann gab's halt auch entsprechende,
Abkommen mit der EU und da wurde natürlich willfährig alles da auch datenmäßig auf die Reise ähm geschickt,
Da gab's dann immer schon ordentlich Widerstand. Dagegen, aber ich glaube, bisher keine einzige wirkliche Einschränkung dieses Prozederes. Korrigiere mich,
Ähm so und jetzt äh steht eine Prüfung an, ob denn das nun alles noch so,
ähm denkbar ist. Insbesondere im Lichte des Urteils der äh zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung durch den Europäischen Gerichtshof durch,
mehrfach äh besprochen haben,
die Entscheidung, die ja wesentlich,
ja, die Implementierung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung in Europa,
mindestens ja erschwert, wenn nicht sogar vollständig verhindert. Ja.
Das ist genau das übrigens, um das nochmal zurückzuführen, die,
Dass das das Vorzahlenspeicherungsurteil geht ja auf den AK Vorrat Österreich zurück.
Und die Crowdfunden sich ja gerade, ich hatte das, glaube ich, in der letzten Folge schon beworben, dass sie sich jetzt die anderen Antiterrorgesetze anschauen wollen. Und schön, es sieht gerade schön aus, dass die,
Das EU-Parlament das jetzt auch mal mit seinem PNR-Abkommen macht und sagt nachts,
dieser, nach diesem VDS-Urteil sieht es doch so aus, als wäre dieses Abkommen im Zweifelsfall auch nicht in Ordnung, dann schien wir es direkt mal auf die Prüfbank zum EUGH. Und jetzt besteht natürlich Hoffnung, dass der EuGH das auch nochmal einsackt.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz schön, dass da jetzt tatsächlich auch drangeblieben wird und dass man mal in die
Offensive geht und vielleicht auch Abkommen und
und Richtlinien und was wir da alles inzwischen an an Antiterrorkram haben, mal einfach sagt, ach, so, okay, lass mal schauen, gib mal her, komm mal her. Vielleicht werden wir es auch tatsächlich auf dem Weg nochmal los. Das finde ich ganz schön hier.
Gab auch durchaus hm wie soll ich sagen, angenehmen, positive,
ähm Entscheidung. Insofern als das im deutlichen Mehrheit auch gefunden wurde im Parlament dafür. Es war jetzt noch nicht mal geklappt. Knappe Entscheidungen, dass du auf die Prüfbank zu stellen. Gut, das heißt jetzt noch lange nicht, dass man sagt,
gar nicht, aber es wird zumindest schon mal nicht verhindert, dass überhaupt geprüft wird, das ist auch schon mal ein ganz guter Punkt.
Prüfen kann man jetzt auch super Überleitung.
Was kann man denn prüfen.
Man kann seinen eigenen Computer prüfen.
Ach, irgendwas?
Ob er mit einem Staatstrojaner infiziert ist. Ja, das ist natürlich jetzt nicht die äh Silver Bullet, aber es gibt eine ähm.
Ein Tool namens Detekt, was,
vorgestellt wurde von verschiedenen ähm,
NGOs, die sich quasi an der äh an dem Bewerben dieses Tools beteiligt haben. Entwickelt wurde es von,
Claudio und ich ich weiß immer nicht, wie man seinen Nachnamen ausspricht.
Oder was ist nicht derjenige, der es gemacht hat? Nee. Doch, der ist das.
Ähm,
ein ähm Forscher, der auch im Citizen Lab da schon ähm,
an vielen derer Analysen beteiligt war. Ganz pfiffiger, junger Mann in diesem Bereich und der,
hat also dieses veröffentlicht von dem er verspricht,
eine Infektion mit verschiedenen Staatstrojan oder verschiedenen bekannten Staatstrojanern ähm erkennt.
Allerdings nur auf Windows und nur auf Windows.
Zweiunddreißig. Bitte. Ah nee, das wurde gefixt. So es äh erkennt den Finn Fischer Finn Spy und den Hacking Tame Hacking Team RCS, also die beiden großen ähm,
Strafverfolgungs äh Staatstrojaner, die bekannt sind.
Und naja, hat am Anfang, glaube ich, auch noch ein paar geworfen, also nicht nervös werden,
wenn äh das Teil bei euch piept,
ähm die Frage bei so einer Veröffentlichung ist natürlich.
Ja, du baust jetzt quasi so ein Tool, das ist auch noch Open Source, das heißt, die Hersteller können natürlich jetzt sehr genau daran arbeiten,
dass sie diesen,
Entdeckungsmechanismen entgehen, die dieses Tool,
Verfügung stellt. Ja, das heißt nicht, dass man so ein Tool nicht veröffentlichen soll.
Es heißt nur, dass es,
wieder nur ein ein weiterer Schritt in diesem Armsrace ist, ja, es ist keine Lösung,
Dieses Tool wird jetzt für, keine Ahnung, im Zweifelsfall, wenn wenn Gamma und Hacking Team ihre Arbeit machen, wirst du damit jetzt schon keine Infektionen mehr finden, weil sie halt wahrscheinlich ihre ganzen ähm
Zielbüchsen halt innerhalb von Windeseile äh geupdatet haben und zwar so, dass sie nicht mehr detektiert werden,
wenn sie denn diese Möglichkeit noch in der Schublade hatten und auf diesen Fall vorbereitet waren,
Es kann natürlich auch sein, dass diese Direktion jetzt so schlau ist, dass sie ähm,
diese Trojaner-Entwickler vor Herausforderungen stellt, denen sie nicht innerhalb kürzester Zeit gewachsen sind,
dann könnte das also dazu führen, dass man dass ein paar Menschen dadurch tatsächlich geholfen ist. So oder so,
dieses Tool, aber.
Die Hersteller dieser Software,
auf jeden Fall Ressourcen, nämlich entweder etwas, was sie in der Hinterhand hatten.
Müssen sie raustun.
Müssen sie jetzt raustun und sich was Neues in die Hinterhand legen oder sie müssen jetzt tatsächlich.
Entschiedene Arbeit leisten, wo ich nicht davon ausgehen würde, dass sie das ernsthaft jetzt äh also sie sollten gut genug vorbereitet gewesen sein für für diesen Fall, den es ja auch schon äh mehrmals gab, dass eben solche äh,
Trojaner
bekannt wurde die irgendwie in die in die Welt entfleucht sind und den mal, wo erforschern in die Hand gekommen sind und auch andere Virenscanner erkennen ja zum Beispiel schon ältere Versionen von Staatstrojanern, ne,
Also es ist ein ein Rennen, was.
Jedem Trojaner Hersteller die ganze Zeit,
beschäftigt. Jeden Trojaner Hersteller die ganze Zeit beschäftigt, ne? Sein ständiges Kämpfen gegen diese,
Viren, Virenscanner, Buden und da, um dafür zu sorgen, dass man irgendwas baut, was die nicht erkennen können.
Damit werden zumindest die Kosten hochgehalten.
Damit werden die Entwicklungskosten hochgehalten, ja. Ist natürlich jetzt auch wieder so eine andere Frage, warum ist das ein,
eine Einzelperson in monatelanger,
Kleinarbeit machen, ja, die in diesem sieht man, dass da Entwicklungs da die Ältesten Dateien, fünf, sechs Monate alt sind.
Also jetzt,
eine Person mit relativ geringem Budget dran gearbeitet. Das ist natürlich ein tolle, tolles Engagement, was da jetzt gezeigt wurde und wenn sich jetzt der die Trojaner updaten, dann wird der neue Signatur noch relativ einfach da einpflegen können,
Man muss eben nur sehen, wo sind die Grenzen von so einer Aktion.
Insofern.
Besser als nichts, sage ich jetzt.
Besser als nichts tolles, tolle Entwicklung, aber ähm wenn jetzt irgendwie Virenscanner,
uns uns der Viren entledigen würden, dann bräuchten wir sie halt inzwischen nicht mehr, ne?
Und dann würde nicht der der Norden Internet,
Security oder was auch immer man auf so einer Windows-Kiste laufen hat äh alle fünf Minuten äh irgendwie zehn Gigabyte neue Signaturen aus dem Internet runterladen wollte. Was auch immer, ne?
Und natürlich noch bei solchen Tools leider eben, das hat sie jetzt implizit ja ohnehin schon, aus dem, was ich gesagt habe, ergeben, nur weil das Tool nichts findet, heißt es nicht, dass du,
nicht infiziert bist. Und äh nur wenn das Tool etwas findet, heißt es leider auch nicht, dass du infiziert bist, ne.
Tja, so ist das. So oder so, wir sind als Ende angekommen.
Wir sind am Ende angelangt. Ja, ich hoffe, ich habe dieses Mal nicht so viel eher gesagt, wie in der letzten Folge,
Ich bin ungefähr genauso müde und durch,
aber ich habe mich wirklich sehr bemüht, nicht zu viel eher zu sagen. Ich fand das in der letzten Folge unerträglich.
Man kann auch schon mal ehrlich sagen.
Ja, aber nicht so viel. Äh habe ich ja keinen einzigen Satz gesagt, ohne ey.
Äh ja, ist ja nur, dass man nachdenkt.
Ja, mache ich aber nicht. Ich rede nur.
Die meisten Sachen, die meisten Sachen, die ich hier sage, über die habe ich vorher nachgedacht,
in der Zeit dazwischen, dann sitze ich dann zu Hause und sagte, äh äh ähm und dann ist Sendung und dann sage ich, ja pass auf und erklär das alles. So, so soll es eigentlich sein.
Termine haben wir jetzt nicht mehr im Angebot.
Ja, wir könnten darauf hinweisen, dass der Vorverkauf des äh für Tickets des,
einunddreißig C drei jetzt angefangen hat.
Mhm. Sichert euch euer Ticket.
Könnten auch darauf hinweisen, dass ein,
der Inhalt des Fahrplanes jetzt auch schon öffentlich ist, allerdings nicht die Uhrzeiten, zu denen geplant ist, diese Sessions sessions stattfinden zu lassen. Es gibt nämlich ein schönes Tool mit dem Namen,
halfnarb, wo man einfach anklicken kann, welche,
interessieren und die da mit Hilfe dieses Tools gesammelten Daten sollen dann das Fahrplan,
Komitee, Ermächtigen.
Kollisionen in den Interessen der Besucher zu minimieren,
Also wenn viele sagen, ich interessiere mich für was weiß ich den,
CCC Jahresrückblick. Ich interessiere mich aber auch,
genauso für ähm.
Weiß ich gar nicht, wofür man sich sonst noch interessieren.
Man kann sich ja für alles Mögliche interessieren.
Einen Vortrag von Richard Storman zum Beispiel, dann ähm kann man das so abschicken,
und dann wird das äh Fahrplansondierungskomitee dafür sorgen, dass wenn das Interesse von vielen Personen ähm überlappt bei diesen Vorträgen,
versucht wird, dass sie nicht in einem und denselben Zeitslot liegen.
Und das ist, glaube ich, für alle ganz äh ganz positiv, weil das nicht immer äh so einfach erkenntlich ist, wofür sich Leute interessieren. Man kann natürlich dadurch nicht alle Kollisionen verhindern,
aber man kann bemüht sein, sie zu minimieren.
Ja, ein Anfang ist gemacht. Ich träume ja schon lange von so einem ähnlichen Tool,
geht hier so, na ja so na ja so halb in die Richtung, die ich gerne gesehen hätte.
Ja, lass uns nicht über die Tools sprechen. Das würde dann die Sendung nur noch viel trauriger machen, als sie ohnehin schon war. Ähm lass uns einfach darauf hoffen, dass viele Menschen sich begeistert zeigen und äh den den Halfnap nutzen
und dass sie, dass es dazu führt, dass dann viele Menschen sich freuen über den,
mit den einunddreißig c drei. Wenn du möchtest, können wir natürlich auch noch ein paar äh Sessions
tschechisch besprechen, aber das können wir auch in der nächsten Folge tun, wenn die Leute schon ihre Tickets gekauft haben.
Genau, das machen wir, das machen wir in der nächsten Folge, weil das passt jetzt heute nicht mehr rein. Ähm ich hab's mir ehrlich gesagt nämlich auch noch nicht äh richtig angeschaut, von daher,
Ja, aber,
auf jeden Fall einiges dabei. Äh einige bekannte Namen, einige vielleicht auch weniger bekannte Namen,
Und so oder so ist der Kongress ja immer eine spannende Geschichte,
Wir werden ja auch wieder mit unserem kleinen Sendezentrum vertreten sein, dort auch nochmal einen eigenen Workshop äh machen.
Ist das weder dahinter, hinten unter der äh Rolltreppe? Volltreppe.
In dem Bereich aber auf der anderen Seite wie es aussieht.
Ähm weil dieser Kongress ja der Erste sein wird, der das CCH komplett nutzt.
Und dadurch neue Räume äh erschlossen werden und durch die neuen Räume werden auch andere Wege und damit auch andere Fluchtwege,
eröffnet und dort wird zum Beispiel ein solcher dann,
sein, was quasi die Raumnutzungsparameter ein wenig verändert hat,
ist nicht so schlimm, wir sind da ganz zufrieden und das äh wird supi und dann werde ich da später auch nochmal ein bisschen mehr zu sagen. Hier,
jetzt machen wir auf jeden Fall erstmal einen Deckel zu, sind hier bei einer runden Stunde gelandet. Ist ja auch mal was Schönes.
Tja, auch ist auch mal schön, wenn zwischendurch nochmal was Schönes gibt. Wenn du dich
zu erfreuen, dann ist das doch schön, dann freue ich mich doch für dich, Tim.
Ganz anspruchslos. So haltet die Ohren steif, bis bald. Bis bald, ciao ciao.
Bis bald, tschau, tschau.